die Uhr tickt in wenigen Tagen ist klar
ob das russische Gas abgestellt bleibt
ob wirtschaftliche Schäden ob soziale
Gefahren drohen die Inflation geht jetzt
schon durch die Decke die Energiepreise
vervielfachen sich also gründe genug um
mit der SPD-Vorsitzenden Saskia esken zu
sprechen und damit herzlich willkommen
zum ZDF sommerinterview
[Musik]
S
ein herzliches Willkommen zum zdfirma
Interview ich grüße sie HALLO
wir sind in der Klosterruine Hirsau in
Calw Nordschwarzwald ihr Wahlkreis und
auch nicht weit von Ihrem Zuhause
entfernt wir treffen uns in gewisser
Weise in einem bitter zweischneidigen
Moment einerseits fahren die Menschen in
Ferien
hier beginnt der Kultursommer wieder
nach zwei Jahren Corona Aussetzung und
gleichzeitig tickt die Uhr wir erfahren
in wenigen Tagen ob diesem Land wichtige
Energie abgeschnitten wird der
Arbeitgeberpräsident warnt das ist die
größte Krise die dieses Land hier hatte
sind das übertriebene Cassandra rufe ich
glaube tatsächlich dass wir schon in
großer Sorge zu Recht auch sind und dass
wir uns auch warten und das tut die
Bundesregierung auch gleichzeitig sind
die Menschen aber nach zweieinhalb
Jahren Corona auch sehr
entspannungsbedürftig nachvollziehbarer
Weise freuen sich darauf dass endlich
wieder Kultur stattfinden kann zumindest
im Freien wie es hier in diesem
wunderschönen Gemäuer seit vielen Jahren
ja schon gemacht wird hier war schon
roger hat es von Supertramp hier war
schon Konstantin Wecker Udo Lindenberg
kommt ja Udo Lindenberg auf die
Formulierung größte Krise die das Land
je hatte
also ich habe eine andere Formulierung
gehört ich habe gehört dass ein
Politikwissenschaftler gesagt hat keine
Regierung seit 1949 hatte so einen
schweren Staat und das ist nicht ganz
von der Hand zu weisen es sind so schon
sehr sehr schwerwiegende Krisen mit
denen wir es zu tun haben auch Krisen
die sich stapeln denn Corona ist ja noch
nicht vorbei und der Krieg ist zurück in
Europa wir haben da schon schwere
Entscheidungen zu treffen und
schwerwiegende auch Vorgänge tatsächlich
zu meistern also genug Themen zu
besprechen bitte schön
[Musik]
die Inflation geht durch die Decke
besonders dramatisch ist es beim Thema
Energie die ersten Gasversorger haben
angekündigt dass Sie die Preise von
1.500 Euro im Jahr auf
4.700 Euro erhöhen an der Börse hat sich
zum Teil der Gaspreis versiebenfacht der
Kanzler warnt vor sozialen Verwerfungen
und sagt eine langanhaltende Krise
voraus stehen wir vor sozialharten
Jahren und Frau Wohlstandsverlust nein
das ist so eine sehr sehr schwere
Belastung für die Menschen die
gestiegenen Energiepreise die ja auch
durchschlagen auf andere Preise auch die
Lebensmittelpreise gerade
grundnahrungsmittel sind ja viel viel
teurer geworden und sind natürlich
Menschen mit niedrigen und mittleren
Einkommen besonders belastet Menschen
mit niedrigen Einkommen da ist oft der
Kühlschrank schon vor das der dem Ende
des Monats leer und der Geldbeutel
ebenso deswegen haben wir natürlich auch
mit den Entlastungsmaßnahmen in einem
Volumen von mehr als 30 Milliarden Euro
ganz gezielt auch diese Menschen
entlastet das müssen wir auch tun und
trotzdem sagen im jüngsten
flippbarometer drei Viertel der Menschen
dass die Bundesregierung sie bei den
Energiepreisen nicht ausreichend
entlastet hat gehen wir mal im
Schnelldurchgang einige der
angesprochenen Entlastungen durch bitte
kurze Antworten Stichwort
kündigungsmoratorium bei Strom und Gas
sind Sie dafür das ist dringend
notwendig um die Menschen Kündigung zu
schützen wenn sie eben in Zahlungsverzug
geraten auch bei der Miete übrigens Herr
Buschmann hat heute dann ein
Fragezeichen gesetzt ja nun Herr
Buschmann ist nicht nicht
Verbraucherschutzminister das wäre er
vielleicht gerne noch war ja mal beim
Justizministerium aber das ist nur liegt
in einem anderen Ressort wir sind aber
gemeinsam der festen Überzeugung dass
wir Menschen schützen müssen Stichwort
Bürgergeld Arbeitsminister Heil will
eine deutliche Anhebung was ist für Sie
deutlich
das Bäume gelten muss an
menschenwürdiges Leben ermöglichen muss
Teilhabe auch ermöglichen an der
Gesellschaft und dazu gerade jetzt unter
den aktuellen Umständen mit der
Inflation ist es nicht mehr geeignet
deswegen haben wir ja auch eine
Entlastung dort einmalig ausgezahlt 2200
Euro pro sind extra bezahlt worden als
einmalige Entlastung aber pro Monat was
schwebt ergibt sich dann muss man keine
Zahlen heute festlegen sondern es ergibt
sich ja aus einer Berechnungsmethode und
diese Berechnungsmethode muss geändert
werden unser Arbeitsminister sagt nicht
die unteren 20 sondern die unteren 30%
der Einkommen müssen in Bezug genommen
werden und dadurch ergibt sich dann eine
Erhöhung Stichwort energiepreisdeckel
unterstützen sie den dgb-vorschlag es
ist ein wichtiger und auch wertvoller
Vorschlag allerdings muss man bedenken
dass wir den sehr sehr lange durchhalten
müssen und er ist relativ teuer und er
ist natürlich auch eine Entlastung für
alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht
gezielt für die mit den geringen
Einkommen da müssen wir uns darauf
konzentrieren Stichwort neun Euro Ticket
soll das verlängert werden der
bayerische Ministerpräsident sagt heute
erfordert ein 365 Euro Jahresticket das
ist eine Forderung die schon auch in
vielen Wahlprogrammen enthalten war ich
glaube im Wahlprogramm der CSU und der
CDU war es nicht enthalten aber es ist
ganz deutlich geworden ja durch dem aus
dem neuen euro-ticket dass wir einen
großen Erfolg erzielt haben das sehr
sehr viele Menschen bezahlbaren möchten
wir werden es weiterentwickeln und auf
eine Art verlängern da gibt es
unterschiedliche Vorschläge auch von den
Versorgungsunternehmen haben wir ja als
solche Vorschläge gehört jetzt ist der
Verkehrsminister am Zug letzter Punkt
Tankrabatt auch da fordert der
bayerische Ministerpräsident heute
Verlängerung über den Winter ja wichtig
wäre ja dass der Tankrabatt auch
tatsächlich ein Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher weitergegeben wird es hat
hier nicht so geklappt deswegen stehen
wir an der Stelle eher vor der Frage wie
schöpfen wir eigentlich übergewinne beim
Mineralölkonzernen ab und bei anderen
die jetzt in dieser Krise ohne eigene
Leistung besondere Profite gemacht haben
das haben sie eine ganze Menge von
finanziellen Entlastungen ja bejaht im
Prinzip das ist eigentlich das leichte
das bezahlen ist das schwierige
Christian Lindner sagt in diesem Jahr
sein keine Entlastungen mehr drin den
beugen Sie sich sicherlich sofort
Christian Lindner verweist auf den
existierenden Haushalt da muss man ja
aber sagen dass wir in den vergangenen
zweieinhalb Jahren Krise denn wir sie
kommen ja schon aus einer
langanhaltenden Krise mit Corona immer
wieder auch die Situation hatten dass
wir Entlastungen oder
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen finanzieren
mussten und haben dann auch die
notwendige Finanzierung gefunden und das
ist auch weiterhin notwendig also es ist
wir werden wenn der Haushalt tatsächlich
im der das nächste Jahr im September und
im Dezember dann beraten wird in erster
und zweiter dritter Lesung werden wir
sehen ob wir tatsächlich die Möglichkeit
haben die Ausnahme von der
Schuldenbremse einzustellen denn wir
stecken ja mitten in der Krise und wir
sehen die Folgen Zeit dieser beiden
Krisen noch gar können wir noch gar
nicht absehen sie sollen wir noch
zurückbremse
erneut aussetzen müssen und dazu kommt
natürlich dass wir jetzt langfristig
auch Entlastungen ermöglichen müssen und
dazu ist sicher auch ein stärkerer
Beitrag der hohen sehr sehr hohen
Einkommen und der so sehr hohen Vermögen
notwendig denn auch die jährliche zwei
Prozent Zusage für die Verteidigung das
kommt ja noch oben drauf auch da wofür
müsste ja noch mal eine Entlastung
gefunden werden wenn die zwei die zwei
Prozent Regel soll ja eingehalten werden
aus den Investitionen des 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögens das für die Bundeswehr
jetzt aufgelegt worden ist da sind wir
jetzt für die nächsten Jahre erstmal
versorgt außerhalb des Haushalts
sozusagen diese Sondervermögen ist ja
mit einer
sonderkreditaufnahme in diesem Jahr
ermöglicht worden
der Koalitionspartner FTP wieder im
Grunde ja Steuererleichterung er sagt
warum soll man in Zeiten von steigenden
Preisen die Menschen nicht auf diesem
Weg entlasten das Schließen sie aber
damit aus
Steuererleichterungen bei der
Einkommensteuer dienen immer in der
Hauptsache denen die ganz viel Steuern
bezahlen also die hohe Verdienste haben
am wenigsten dienen sie wenig denen sie
den mittleren Einkommen und gar nicht
eigentlich den geringen Einkommen die
bezahlen gar keine Einkommensteuer weil
die Einkommen so gering sind und
deswegen ist es keine Methode die
Bevölkerung breit zu entlasten da müssen
wir andere Wege finden im übrigen haben
wir im Rahmen der entlastungspakete ja
bereits den Grundfreibetrag angehoben
auch den Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag
angehoben das ist ja schon eine
steuerliche Entlastung sie haben jetzt
all die Entlastungen angesprochen aber
offensichtlich sind sie beim Bürger in
der Form nicht angekommen denn diese
zeitenwände SPD kommt in den Umfragen
nicht besonders gut an mein Blick von
Bernd Benthin auf ihre Partei in 60
Sekunden
im Dezember dachte die SPD noch jetzt
sei sie zurück im Glück
wir sind einfach nur stolz auf unsere
alte Tante SPD genossen die schweren
Jahre der Partei liegen hinter uns
wirklich schwer wurde es dann hinterher
schon die Impfpflicht kriegt der Kanzler
nicht durch die SPD mit wenig Wumms
weggetaucht nach Kriegsbeginn in der
Ukraine nach der verkündeten Zeitenwende
fehlt vielen auch in der Ampel die
Führung die sie bestellt hatten wir
haben zu führen und für die die diese
Rolle nicht annehmen wollen sage ich
dann sitzen sie womöglicherweise im
falschen Moment am falschen Platz das
eigene Personal angezählt siehe
Lambrecht siehe Lauterbach im Saarland
gewinnt die SPD noch eine Wahl danach
historische Tiefstände in
Schleswig-Holstein im einstigen
Stammland NRW auch die Bundes-SPD
schmiert ab aktuell Platz 3 klar hinter
Union und Grünen es waren schwere Jahre
es könnten schwere werden
freies ging dass die Partei des Kanzlers
auf Platz drei in den Umfragen landet
das hat es in der bundesdeutschen
Geschichte noch nicht gegeben und dass
der Kanzler selber auf Platz 4 ist noch
hinter seinem eigenen Arbeitsminister
können Sie uns das erklären na ehrlich
gesagt haben wir in dieser Regierung und
natürlich auch als Partei Wichtigeres zu
tun wenn Bürgerinnen und Bürger unter
der Inflation echt sind wenn die
Industrie auch sich große Sorgen macht
wegen der Gasversorgung oder auch wegen
des Fachkräftemangels der jetzt durch
Corona noch mal verschärft wird da haben
wir was wichtiges zu tun als auf
Umfragen zu blicken ganz ehrlich im
Moment spiegelt es darum und sie sehen
ja
wie der Kanzler auch agiert dass der
Bundeskanzler diese nicht nur diese
Regierung sondern das Land führt auf
internationalen Gipfeln auch deutlich
macht das ist darum gehen muss diese
vielfältigen Krisen die wir jetzt haben
die Bürger nicht zu überzeugen diese
auch mit ruhiger Hand tatsächlich uns
dort durchzusteuern aber vor allem auch
in guter Kooperation mit anderen und der
dieser moderierende Führungsstil der
kooperativen Führungsstil den Olaf
schölster an den Tag legt der ist genau
richtig ich bin sehr froh dass wir Olaf
Scholz im Bundeskanzleramt sitzen haben
ich bin davon überzeugt das geht in
meisten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch so
aber das wie gesagt spiegelt sich nicht
in den Umfragen sie selbst sind Mitglied
der parlamentarischen linken also der
stärksten Partei innerhalb ihrer
Fraktion hat die zeitenwände auch die
parlamentarische linke bleiben verändert
oder hält sie nur still an die SPD
hatten natürlich insgesamt mit dieser
Situation das
putinskrieg den er nach Europa
zurückgetragen hat gegen die Ukraine
viele Gewissheiten auch in Frage
gestellt hat die wir in den letzten
Jahren uns zurechtgelegt hatten auch
Völkerrecht dass uns als wichtige
Grundlage für den Frieden ja gedient hat
in Frage zu stellen da hat die SPD
natürlich auch sich damit zu
beschäftigen und dann kommen Krisen dazu
wie
da die werden eine weltweite Pandemie
die ja auch große Belastungen für die
Bevölkerung und auch für die für die
Wirtschaft mit sich gebracht haben das
sind schwere Zeiten ist das und ich bin
froh wie gesagt dass die SPD die
Regierung führen darf ist das eine Art
neue Realpolitik für die SPD
Verantwortungsethik oder wohin
entwickelt sich die SPD die SPD tut hat
in 160 Jahren bestehen nichts anderes
getan als mit Realpolitik auf die sich
verändernde Situationen der Welt zu
reagieren und dennoch sind unsere
Grundhaltungen ja immer dieselben
geblieben unsere Grundwerte da können
wir auch stolz drauf sein dass wir die
in 160 Jahren nicht ändern müssten und
mussten Freiheit Solidarität und
Gerechtigkeit sind weiterhin Leitlinien
unseres Handelns ihr Vater wurde mit 17
Jahren eingezogen im Krieg ihre Mutter
vertrieben neben ihren
sozialdemokratischen Eltern war Willy
Brandt eine oder die große Leitfigur
ihrer Jugend und von diesem Willy Brandt
stammt eine klare Ansage der Krieg darf
kein Mittel der Politik sein hören wir
mal was
Q SPD-Vorsitzender Lars Klingenberg dazu
kürzlich gesagt hat Friedenspolitik
bedeutet deshalb für mich auch
militärische Gewalt als legitimes Mittel
der Politik zu sehen
verraten sie da gerade ihren Willy
Brandt oder wurde dieser Satz von Putina
schlagen wenn ich glaube ganz deutlich
sagen zu können dass auch Willy Brandt
immer auch in seiner Ostpolitik ganz
klar gemacht hat dass unsere
Friedenspolitik eine wehrhafte
Friedenspolitik sein muss was immer
deutlich auch sein muss dass wir bereit
sind unser Land zu verteidigen dass wir
im westlichen Bündnis in der NATO auch
bereit sind unsere
Bündnisverpflichtungen zu erfüllen dass
wir uns gegenseitig beiseite stehen
beistehen und diese
beistandsverpflichtungen auch erfüllende
insofern ist da keine keine Neuigkeit zu
erkennen es ist Krieg darf kein Mittel
der Politik sein sagte das ist auch
Sachen weiterhin ganz sicher kein Mittel
der deutschen Außenpolitik Krieg zu
führen von unserer Seite aus
Angriffskriege wie sie Putin jetzt gegen
die Ukraine
angefangen hat sind sind tierische
Gewalt als legitimes Mittel der Politik
zu sehen das was Putin getan hat ist
völkerrechtswidrig ganz klar und
deswegen ist es auch vollkommen legitim
dass die Ukraine sich mit mit allem auch
mit unserer Unterstützung dagegen wird
um übrigens auch deutlich zu machen dass
das Recht ist stärkeren nicht die Stärke
des Rechts über Regeln darf deswegen ist
es richtig dort auch militärische Mittel
einzusetzen und auch es ist auch richtig
und übrigens eine ein eine Veränderung
der außenpolitischen
sicherheitspolitischen Maxime der
deutschen Politik dort Waffen
hinzuliefern in ein Kriegsgebiet und mit
vollkommener Zustimmung auch der
SPD-Fraktion und auch der
SPD-Vorsitzender spricht von
Führungsmacht der
SPD-Fraktionschef möchte nicht hat
gestern widersprochen
der Weg sei führungsverbund was sagt
denn saskia ist Saskia eskim orientiert
sich auch am Kanzler der jetzt in einem
Gastbeitrag deutlich gemacht hat dass es
darum geht dass man zusammenführt ich
habe vorher von einer moderierenden und
kooperativen führungs
von einem Stil gesprochen den Olaf
Scholz pflegten der in der in der
multipolaren Welt die wir haben ja auch
dringend notwendig ist wir müssen immer
wieder neue Bündnisse schmieden müssen
auf Augenhöhe auch denen begegnen die
eine immer stärkere Rolle spielen ich
glaube das gelingt Olaf Schulz sehr gut
und da geht es eben darum
zusammenzuführen und zusammen gemeinsam
zu führen also wesentliche Stimmen in
der Ampel in der FDP kann er
offensichtlich damit nicht beeindrucken
noch diese Woche ich darf Ihnen mal aus
einem Tweet Zitieren von Frau Strack
Zimmermann ich erwarte aus dem
Kanzleramt klare Führung und
entsprechendes Handeln denn nach wie vor
gilt hier Fehlanzeige
ich habe Joe beiden beim g7-gipfel
gehört das oder Scholz einen
maßgeblichen Beitrag dazu geleistet habe
dass die G7 dass die NATO oder die EU
stärker als je zuvor zusammen steht die
internationale Gemeinschaft der
freiheitlich demokratisch orientierten
Staaten so gut zusammensteht sei seine
Leistung das finde ich ist Testat genug
das heißt also Frau streikt Zimmermann
ist da auf dem falschen Gleis Frau
streckt Zimmermann Markt ist beurteilen
wie sie hier ist beurteilt in der
Regierung stehen auch in der
ampelregierung stehen da alle zusammen
du schlägt sie heute eine
ukraine-konferenz aller Beteiligten vor
was halten Sie denn davon na ich bin da
festen Überzeugung dass die nationale
der der nationale Sicherheitsrat den die
Regierung ja besitzt und regelmäßig
einberuft uns gerade in der Frage der
Unterstützung der Ukraine im
Zusammenspiel mit den internationalen
Partnern das ist kein von ganz
besonderer Bedeut darum dass man da
keine allein gegen macht dass die dort
die richtige und wichtige Rolle spielen
das Frau stark Zimmermann nicht
vertreten ist in diesem Gremium
maxi-grämen aber es ist ein
regierungsgremium das auch die richtigen
Entscheidungen trifft der große in Calw
geborene Dichter Hermann Hesse der ja
auch hier im Sommer in der Kultursommer
vorkommt hat gesagt ich zitiere noch mal
das Paradies pflegt sich erst dann als
Paradies zu erkennen zu geben wenn wir
daraus vertrieben wurden lässt sie das
an die nahe Zukunft denken
sind ja dazu angetreten in der Regierung
dafür zu sorgen dass es den Menschen im
Land gut geht dass es ihnen besser geht
dass wir Schaden von ihnen abwenden und
das ist eine fortwährende Aufgabe
insofern wir haben uns nicht im Paradies
Befunden nicht in der Vergangenheit wir
haben hohe soziale Ungleichheiten in
Deutschland wir haben
ungleich verteilte Bildungschancen an
vieles andere mehr wo wir dran gehen
müssen und wir haben internationale
Krisen mit die wir bewältigen müssen
insofern im Paradies habe ich mich auch
vorher nicht gewählt sagen sie sich sehr
im Moment es gibt Anlass zu Sorge die
internationale Lage gibt Anlass zu Sorge
aber ich weiß dass unser Land stark ist
dass der Zusammenhalt in Deutschland
stark ist die konzertierte Aktion die
Olaf Scholz jetzt ins Leben gerufen hat
ist ein Zeichen davon dass wir im
Konsens in Deutschland solche
krisenhaften Situationen bewältigen bei
der ersten Auflage der der konzertierten
Aktion gab es eine Ölpreiskrise
das Bündnis der Arbeit das Ende der 90er
Jahre in einem Griff in
einberufen wurde hat ja auf die
Arbeitslosigkeit und eine sehr hohe
Arbeitslosigkeit reagiert und dort wurde
jeweils immer gemeinsam zwischen
Arbeitgeberseite und Gewerkschaften und
Politik würden eben gemeinsame Maßnahmen
verabredet die gemeinsam die tragen sind
im Konsens sind solche Krisen zu
bewältigen freistellig danke Ihnen für
das Gespräch
das war unser sommerinterview mit der
SPD-Vorsitzenden Saskia esken in der
kommenden Woche trifft meine Kollegin
schakodella bernergy den
CDU-Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend und eine gute
Woche
[Musik]